THAT CAME OUT OF THIS AND
KEPT ME GOING THROUGH ALL OF
IT JUST REEMPHASIZED HOW
WONDERFUL MOST PEOPLE ARE.
♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
A BIG NEWS DAY.
MAYBE A PIVOTAL ONE.
THE DOJ RELEASED ITS LONG
AWAITED INTERNAL REVIEW
WRITTEN BY THE DEPARTMENT'S
INSPECTOR GENERAL AND IT'S
PACKED WITH INFORMATION.
IN A FEW MINUTES DONALD
TRUMP JR. WILL JOIN TO US
RESPOND TO IT.
FIRST, WHAT IS IN THE REPORT
IN THE DOCUMENT IS MORE THAN
500 PAGES LONG AND PARTS OF
IT ARE COMPLEX.
AND, YET, WITHIN MINUTES OF
ITS RELEASE, THE HAIR SPRAY
GENIUSES OF CABLE NEWS HAD
IT NEATLY SUMMARIZED FOR THE
REST OF US.
IT WAS A TOUGH DAY FOR THE
FBI, THEY SAID.
HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
A MONTH'S LONG INVESTIGATION
FOUND NO EVIDENCE THAT
POLITICAL BIAS PLAYED ANY
ROLE IN THIS HIGH PROFILE
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
THAT'S ALMOST VERBATIM WHAT
THEY SAID ON THE OTHER
CHANNELS.
WE WATCHED.
AND THEY REPEATED IT NEARLY
WORD FOR WORD AT THE TOP OF
EVERY HOUR ALL DAY LONG.
ALMOST LIKE A TALKING POINT.
WHICH, OF COURSE, IS WHAT IT
WAS.
KEEP THIS IN MIND, IF YOU
LOOING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
ACTUALLY HAPPENING IN THIS
COUNTRY, ALWAYS ASSUME THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT THEY ARE
TELLING YOU ON THE BIG NEWS
STATIONS.
AND THAT'S CERTAINLY THE
CASE HERE.
THEY ARE LYING.
IN FACT, TODAY'S IG REPORT
IS A VIRTUAL CATALOG OF
POLITICAL BIAS AND ABUSE OF
POWER.
IT IS TRUE THAT
INVESTIGATORS FOUND NO
EVIDENCE AT ALL THAT JIM
COMEY WAS TRYING TO SABOTAGE
HILLARY CLINTON'S
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
NO SURPRISE THERE.
COMEY IS A PARTISAN DEMOCRAT
AS HE HAS EXPLAINED
REPEATEDLY ON HIS BOOK TOUR.
THE BIAS, AND THERE WAS A
LOT OF IT, WAS AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP AND HIS
CAMPAIGN.
AND THERE IS AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF THAT ON DISPLAY IN
THIS REPORT.
TRUMP IS A LOATHESOME HUMAN
FBI LAWYER LISA PAGE WROTE
TO HER BOYFRIEND FBI
OFFICIAL PETER STRZOK.
HE IS AN IDIOT.
AWFUL, ENORMOUS DOUCHE, A
DISASTER, HE SIMPLY CANNOT
BE PRESIDENT.
IS HE NOT EVER GOING TO
BECOME PRESIDENT.
RIGHT?
SHE WROTE TO STRZOK AT ONE
POINT?
NO STRZOK REPLIED, NO; NO HE
WON'T.
WE WILL STOP IT.
KEEP IN MIND THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE RUNNING THE
INVESTIGATIONS INTO DONALD
TRUMP AND HILLARY CLINTON IN
THE MIDDLE OF A PRESIDENTIAL
RACE.
IT'S ALMOST UNBELIEVABLE.
BUT DO YOU KNOW WHAT'S EVEN
MORE UNBELIEVABLE?
PETER STRZOK STILL WORKS AT
THE FBI.
THE MAN WHO PROMISED TO STOP
A PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
FROM GETTING ELECTED IS
STILL COLLECTING A SALARY AT
OUR MOST POWERFUL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
IF YOU ARE LOOKING FOR
EVIDENCE OF POLITICAL BIAS,
THERE YOU HAVE IT.
AND IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE IT,
IMAGINE THIS HEADLINE, FOR
EXAMPLE, SAY 10 YEARS AGO,
BARACK OBAMA SIMPLY CANNOT
BECOME PRESIDENT, WE WILL
STOP HIM, WROTE FBI AGENT
PETER STRZOK WHO STILL WORKS
AT THE BUREAU.
CAN YOU IMAGINE?
NO, YOU WOULD BE FIRED
IMMEDIATELY, FIRST AMENDMENT
BE DAMNED.
AND BY THE WAY STRZOK AND
PAGE WERE NOT ALONE.
THEY ARE NOT EVEN THE
STANDOUT CASES IN THIS
REPORT.
THE DOCUMENT QUOTES ANOTHER
FBI ATTORNEY, WONDERING,
QUOTE:  WHAT I COULD HAVE
DONE DIFFERENTLY TO STOP
DONALD TRUMP'S ELECTION AS
PRESIDENT.
THAT SAME OFFICIAL LATER
DESCRIBES HIMSELF AS PART OF
THE ANTI-TRUMP RESISTANCE.
FOR SOME REASON THE DOJ IS
HIDING THAT LAWYER'S NAME
FROM THE PUBLIC.
WEAVE DO KNOW HE SERVED ON
THE MUELLER TEAM UNTIL
FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR.
OF COURSE HE DID.
AND THERE'S A LOT MORE IN
THE REPORT.
HUNDREDS OF PAGES OF IT.
IT TURNS OUT JIM COMEY USED
A PERSONAL EMAIL ACCOUNT TO
CONDUCT GOVERNMENT BUSINESS,
JUST LIKE THE WOMAN HE WAS
IN THE PROCESS OF
INVESTIGATING FOR DOING THE
SAME THING.
IRONY ALERT.
HILLARY'S SECRET SERVER, BY
THE WAY IT DID INDEED HAVE
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION ON
IT.
SOME OF THAT INFORMATION WAS
OBTAINED BY A FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE SERVICE.
AT LEAST ONE.
REMEMBER WE SUGGESTED THAT
VERY THING AND THEY SCOFFED
DERISIVELY?
IT TURNS OUT IT'S TRUE, LIKE
SO MUCH.
THE REPORT GOES ON TO REVEAL
THAT FBI AGENTS ROUTINELY
TOOK BRIBES FROM JOURNALISTS JOU
TOOK BRIBES FROM JOURNALISTS JON
TOOK BRIBES FROM JOURNALISTS JOL
TOOK BRIBES FROM JOURNALISTS JOS
IN RETURN FOR LEAKING
INFORMATION.
PEOPLE GONE TO JAIL FOR
THINGS LIKE THAT IN
WASHINGTON.
OF COURSE NOBODY NOE ONE AT
FBI WAS SERIOUSLY PENALIZED
FOR IT.
IT GOES ON LIKE THIS.
THE FBI IS OUT OF CONTROL.
THE CURRENT DIRECTOR CHRIS
WRAY ACKNOWLEDGED AS MUCH
TODAY AT THE PRESS
CONFERENCE.
LUCKILY WRAY HAS A SOLUTION.
GOING FORWARD, HE SAID, FBI
EMPLOYEES WILL RECEIVE
PROFESSIONAL ANTIBIAS
TRAINING.
NOW, THAT MIGHT NOT MAKE THE
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS LESS
CORRUPT, BUT IT WILL
DEFINITELY BRING A
HEIGHTENED SENSE OF
SENSITIVITY TO QUESTIONS OF
TRANSGENDER BATHROOMS AND
TOXIC MASCULINITY.
THAT MIGHT MAKE YOU FEEL
BETTER.
FOX CHIEF INTELLIGENCE
CORRESPONDENT CATHERINE
HERRIDGE HAS BEEN ON THIS
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING AND
JOINS US NOW WITH A REPORT.
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY IS THE
SUM OF THE IMPRESSION THAT
YOU GET OF DIRECTOR COMEY
FROM THIS REPORT, CATHERINE?
>> WELL, THIS IS THE REPORT
RIGHT HERE, TUCKER.
AND IT'S AS YOU MENTIONED
OVER 500 PAGES LONG.
AND THE BOTTOM LINE WITH
DIRECTOR COMEY IS THAT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL FOUND THAT
HE WAS INSUBBOARD NANT WHEN
HE MADE THAT JULY 2016
PUBLIC STATEMENT ABOUT THE
CLINTON EMAIL CASE WHERE
DIRECTOR COMEY RECOMMENDED
AGAINST CRIMINAL CHARGES FOR
THE MISHANDLING OF
INFORMATION AND THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL SAID THAT
COMEY DELIBERATELY HID WHAT
HE WAS GOING TO SAY FROM HIS
BOSS, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
LORETTA LYNCH, AND HER
DEPUTY SALLY YATES.
AND THERE WAS NO OTHER WAY
TO DESCRIBE IT BUT IT
AMOUNTED TO INSUBORDINATION.
I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE, FOR COMEY, RATHER,
IT'S PART OF HIS LEGACY,
RIGHT?
HE HAS DONE A BOOK ABOUT
LOYALTY.
HE IS TOURING THE COUNTRY
TALKING ABOUT LEADERSHIP.
AND THIS REALLY IS SORT OF A
FOOTNOTE OR A BOOK END ON
HIS LEGACY, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: ONE OF THE
HEADLINES OF THIS REPORT
WHICH WE JUST QUOTED AT SOME
LENGTH WAS THE TEXT MESSAGE
FROM PETER STRZOK TO LISA
PAGE.
>> RIGHT.
>> Tucker: PROMISED WE WILL
STOP HIM.
>> RIGHT.
>> Tucker: MR. STRZOK STILL
WORKS AT THE FBI.
HAS THERE BEEN ANY
INDICATION OF WHETHER THERE
WILL BE CONSEQUENCES FOR
HIM?
>> RIGHT.
SO, WHAT WE LEARNED TODAY
FROM THE FBI DIRECTOR IS
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO REFER
SOME OF THE EMPLOYEES FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTION.
AND I JUST WANT TO KIND OF
DECODE THAT FOR YOU A BIT.
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTION IS NOT
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION.
AND FOR MANY OF THESE PEOPLE
WHO ARE, YOU KNOW, IMPLICATE
YOU HAD IN THE REPORT, THEY
HAVE ALREADY LEFT THE
BUREAU.
THEY HAVE RETIRED OUT.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> THEY HAVE JUST LEFT ON
THEIR OWN OR THEY HAVE BEEN,
YOU KNOW, REASSIGNED.
STRZOK IS STILL THERE.
AND BASED ON WHAT WE READ IN
THE REPORT TODAY, THERE
SEEMS TO BE EVIDENCE, AS YOU
MENTION YOU, OF THIS
POLITICAL BIAS.
AND IF I COULD JUST SAY ONE
THING, I THINK IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO PAY ATTENTION
TO THE LANGUAGE IN THE
REPORT.
WHAT THEY SAY IS THAT THEY
DIDN'T FIND TESTIMONIAL OR
DOCUMENTARY EVIDENCE.
SO NO PAPERWORK AND NO
WITNESS TESTIMONY THAT
POLITICAL BIAS INFECTED THE
DECISIONS OF THE CLINTON
EMAIL CAMPAIGN
INVESTIGATION, PARDON ME.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN IT DIDN'T
HAPPEN OR IT WASN'T THERE.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> THEY ARE SAYING THEY
DIDN'T FIND EVIDENCE OF IT,
RIGHT?
I THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT